most of us have heard about lockheed
martin they're a defense contractor that
works with the us military
and nasa but if you don't follow the
military too closely
you may be shocked hearing how big the
company really is
today lockheed martin is worth about 180
billion
dollars employing a massive 110 000
employees
what's even more surprising though is
that roughly 75
of their entire revenue comes from one
source the us government
in fact they won nearly 40 billion
dollars from the us government
in 2020 alone so how is lockheed martin
able to go into the us government's
right hand man well the story of
lockheed martin dates back over 100
years to 1912.
two brothers named allen and the malcolm
lockheed wear everyday auto mechanic
living paycheck to paycheck
though money was tied they were always
able to find a bit of money to spend on
their hobby
which was building a seaplane that they
could use in the nearby san francisco
bay
this process however would be
significantly pushed forward
after they convinced an investor named
max mamlock to invest into their plane
max mamlock was a local businessman who
owned a company called the alco cab
company
the lockheed brothers would convince max
that there was a sizeable market looking
for airplane rides
and tours so in 1912 max would go ahead
and create a new company called the alco
hydra
aeroplane company with four thousand
dollars that's the same
as about 108 000 today after taking this
investment in
the brothers were able to really push
for the development of their model g
airplane during the following year on
june 15
1913 alan lockhee would make his first
successful fight in the model g
flying from the golden gate to the san
francisco bay that same day
allen would complete two more successful
flights with the model g
despite this rapid start though not very
many people could afford to spend 10
or 271 dollars a day to go on a joyride
in an airplane
also the people who could afford it
didn't really trust the plane
henry ford apparently stated quote i
would not take even a straightaway
flight four feet above the bay
in anybody's airplane for all the money
in california
given this lackluster response from the
market mamlock would decide to shut down
the operations
and keep the plane for himself he had
fronted all the capital
so this makes sense he did give the
lockheed brothers the opportunity to buy
the plane from him
if they could come up with the 4 dollars
invested in the business
as we know though the lockheed brothers
were more or less broke
so they decided to start mining gold
hoping that they could hit it big
they tried this for two years but found
very little success in the mining
industry
attempting a more realistic path the
brothers would look for a financier that
believed in their business
and this would end up being a french
philologist named paul meyer
paul would help her brothers by their
plane from max in 1915
and the brothers would start a small
flying business in the panama pacific
international exposition
this exposition attracted over 18
million people to san francisco
and unlike the citizens of san francisco
these visitors were extremely interested
in taking a flight over the san
francisco bay
within just five months after starting
the business the brothers would fly 600
passengers
profiting the full 4 thousand dollars
realizing that the key to their success
was targeting the right demographic
the brothers would move the business to
santa barbara where enthusiasm for
flying was much higher
the move would be extremely successful
and the lockheed brothers would even
expand to providing commercial flights
for movie production
and private charter trips despite this
massive success though
the lockheed brothers weren't fully
satisfied they had a cash cow on their
hands but their goal was never to become
a tourist pilot
the real dream was building aircrafts
now that the company was making money
they finally had the freedom to step
aside and design new planes
in 1916 the company was to work on the
f1 flying boat
and after development was completed
allen would visit washington dc
looking to sell his plane to the navy
unfortunately allen would find out that
the navy could only buy planes that were
previously approved
so allen would try his luck with the
army but before they could transition to
f1 to a land plane
world war one would come to an end not
only did this kill lockheed's chances
and selling to the army
but lockheed would face a much bigger
issue you see
the military had bought an excess amount
of planes before world war one
and now that the war was over the
military would sell these plans for dirt
cheap
to put this in perspective lockheed's
newest plane the s-1
cost two thousand five hundred dollars
meanwhile the military was selling their
planes for three 300
given that it was impossible to
successfully compete against these
prices
the investors of lockheed aircraft would
decide to take their profits and shut
down their company in 1921.
around the same time another aviator
named glendale martin
also had a grand vision for
manufacturing aircrafts just like
lockheed
martin would start his airplane company
in 1912 and name it the glenn l martin
company
unlike the lockheed brothers though
martin not only had access to capital
but he also had a clear plan from the
very beginning
martin targeted selling aircrafts in the
military during world war one
and so he started out building military
trainer planes
the famous wright brothers would
actually notice what martin was doing
and they would jump on the opportunity
very early on
in 1916 the right company would offer to
merge with the glenn l martin company
and martin would accept however martin
quickly realized that he far preferred
the free time he had
when running his own company and he
would leave the merge company just one
year later and formed a new gleno martin
company
with the help of several american
industrialists in 1917
right after forming a new company martin
would jump into manufacturing the mb-1
bomber
which was their first major success the
key characteristic that set apart the
mb-1 bomber from other aircrafts
was its sheer size the aircraft came in
at 10
000 pounds with a 72-foot wingspan in
fact
the aircraft was so big that when martin
and his team flew the aircraft to show
it to the us military
the guards at the airport arrested them
thinking that they were european bombers
they would only sell 20 of these
aircrafts but for a company that was
brand new
that was not bad at all moreover
martin would quickly follow up with the
mb-2 which the army loved
the army would order 20 right off the
bat and they would follow up with a 110
unit order
martin would work on fulfilling his
orders throughout the 1920s
and after he completed his order he
would actually sell his manufacturing
facilities in 1928.
martin wanted to focus on engine
technology so he would use the proceeds
from selling his manufacturing
facilities
to buy a 90 stick and louis chevrolet's
airplane engine company
just by looking at the origins of either
company you can see that martin
and the lockheed brothers had radically
different approaches
martin was extremely goal-oriented and
was looking to leverage his airplane
knowledge to grow a large company
meanwhile the lockheed brothers really
just wanted to earn a nice living
working on airplanes
though they had starkly different
approaches one characteristic that was
consistent between the two
was persistence after lockheed's company
was shut down in 1921
he would team up with a brick intel
manufacturer named freddie keeler
and he would start the lockheed aircraft
company in 1926
this would result in the development of
the vega airplane the vega would go on
to complete the first successful solo
fight around the world in 1933.
both companies would have a bit of
trouble during the great depression
the companies themselves were doing fine
but the same could not be said
about the investors so we saw a couple
of shifts in investors throughout the
1930s
but given the success of the products
put out by either company
they would make it through the 1930s
unlike many other aircraft companies
and this put them in the perfect
position to manufacture airplanes for
world war
ii this would be the first time lockheed
got to form a serious partnership with
the military
given that they were a bit too late
during world war one lockheed would end
up producing the p-38 lightning fighter
interceptor
and the p-80 shooting star both of these
aircrafts were icons in world war
ii the p-38 was quote the only american
pursuit plane to remain in continuous
production
throughout the war similarly the p-80
became the first american jet aircraft
to enter service
as for the martin company they weren't
quite as successful as lockheed
throughout world war
ii but they do sold planes like the b-26
border to the military
the main downfall for the martin company
was that they were trying to expand into
the commercial transport business
and this just wasn't working for them as
a result
after world war ii the two companies
would head in different directions
lockheed had grown into one of the top
choices for the us military for
aircrafts
so they were easily able to transition
to producing transport vehicles for the
military like the c-130 hercules
throughout the 1950s lockheed was able
to win a variety of contracts allowing
them to easily breeze through the decade
but things would take a quick turn in
the 1960s
things did start off alright in the
1960s lockheed got two major contracts
one for the c-5 galaxy military
transport and one for the l-1011 tristar
wide body civil airliner
however both projects would see massive
cost overruns
and delays this would put lockheed in a
position where they had plenty of work
to do
but they were losing money doing the
work which caused them to take on over a
billion dollars in debt
to make things even worse it would be
revealed in 1975 and 1976
that lockheed had actually been bribing
foreign officials to buy their aircrafts
throughout the 1950s
and the 1960s throughout that time
period lockheed had paid out 22 million
dollars in bribes
this no not severely hurt lockheed's
reputation
meanwhile the modern company was
actually not doing too bad
they did completely stop making
aircrafts but they were able to find a
decent amount of success selling
missiles and space launchers to the
military
and nasa throughout the cold war they
helped nasa build things like the viking
landers and the magellan spacecraft
seeing martin's success outside of
aircrafts lockheed would decide to focus
on their own missiles business
given their brand reputation with
aircrafts in 1977
they would change your name from the
lockheed aircraft company to the
lockheed corporation
and throughout the 1980s and early 1990s
both lockheed and martin would go on an
acquisition spree as cold war tensions
started to loosen
lockheed for instance would go ahead and
acquire meteor management systems in
sanders associates in 1986 and general
dynamics fort worth aircraft division in
1993.
concurrently martin would purchase
general electric aerospace business in
and general dynamic space systems
division in 1994.
with the collapse of the soviet union in
1991 though
both lockheed and martin knew that there
was going to be significant downfalls in
their respective revenues
despite their recent acquisitions but
the ceo of lockheed corp
daniel m telep had just the solution on
march 19th
1994 he would call the ceo of martin
marietta
and propose a merger of equals sure
enough
one year later on march 15 1994 the
second
and third largest american defense
contractors would merge
forming a lockheed martin that we know
today
at the time this was more of a survival
move rather than a monopolistic move
little did they know about the turn of
events that would follow 2001
which allowed them to dominate the
defense contractor space
since then lockheed martin's stock has
exploded from 27
after the merger in 1995 to almost 400
today and that's how lockheed martin
became the military's
right-hand man did you guys know about
the rich history of lockheed martin
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys thought this video described
your past
well and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one